eu gostaria que você imaginar sem aquela
criança de oito anos um pouco imperativa
que os pais pisca olhar ela tem cima de
alguma coisa correndo ou saltando por aí
eu era criança
e nessa mesma fase que eu conheci o
parkour
eu sempre fui apaixonada por desafio
estava sempre os lugares mais altos mais
difícil de escalar só que um dia eu
estava num almoço de família juntamente
com os meus pais e meu irmão e de
repente um documentário na tv com alguns
adultos saltando coisas e se movimentam
ao redor da cidade
aquilo ali parecia uma coisa pouco
familiar pra mim porque eu já era de
ficar plano por aí fazendo alguma coisa
sempre muito muito relacionada com essas
coisas de esportes assim de ficar plano
brincando brincando de pega pega e tudo
mais
e quando eu percebi que aquilo ali
poderia ser um esporte que aquilo ali
poderia ser uma prática o método vem na
hora de pesquisar sobre o que era
percurso e juntamente com o irmão na
época encontra alguns sites blogs alguns
vídeos no youtube e começamos a ir numa
pracinha onde costumava jogar futebol e
simplesmente reproduzir aquilo que
assistir só que eu comecei a perceber
aquela definição que as pessoas tinham a
respeito do porco era um pouco limitada
porque ela é muito linear
geralmente as pessoas diziam ah porque
sua como ver um ponto a 1 ponto b da
forma mais rápida e eficiente possível e
ela sempre sempre focada em velocidade e
nada mais
eu comecei a perceber aquilo ali tinha
um significado maior era como se eu
conseguisse ressignificar o ambiente à
minha volta e utilizava o próprio corpo
na própria movimentação para explorar o
ambiente para trazer algo mais e opaco e
se relaciona também com essa volta da
movimentação que a gente vai perdendo
com o tempo porque o ser humano conforme
a gente foi evoluindo com a tecnologia
a gente foi regredindo no quesito de
explorar o nosso corpo realmente criar
uma identidade de movimento e eu comecei
a me relacionar com isso e fui me
apaixonando cada vez mais pelo percurso
só que nessa mesma fase está passando
por alguns problemas
eu havia parado de crescer ea diferença
de altura entre os meus amigos de classe
ela era de casa 15 ou 20 centímetros
a gente não sabe o porquê daquilo e foi
quando eu os meus pais ea gente resolveu
pela cidade vizinha procurar um médico
endocrinologista e descobrir o porquê
daquele problema
depois desse tipo de exames vieram os
resultados e eu lembro até hoje tenha me
contando a notícia de que foi o que me
abalou muito porque eu havia parado de
produzir o hormônio do crescimento gh e
se eu quisesse continuar dali pra frente
tem uma vida normal álbum continuar
minha vida normalmente
eu tenho que me submeter a um tratamento
que consistia em uma injeção do hormônio
por dia e algumas mudanças em hábitos
alimentares de sono mas toda a medição
por dia não foi o que mais embalo
eu ficava repetindo a minha cabeça
várias vezes de que eu só queria ser
normal e aquilo ali me trazer um
sentimento de impotência e incapacidade
que eu entendi de onde vinha era muito
pequena para entender de onde vinha
aquele sentimento mas foi nessa fase que
entende que se eu quiser superar isso eu
teria que focar mais e utilizar mais do
meu tempo aquilo que gostava de fazer
que é um dos esportes e entre os meus 18
até os 14 anos eu pratiquei diversos
deles desde balé karatê futebol escalada
corrida provas com cavalos xadrez skate
e o parkour
ele permaneceu por um motivo muito
específico é muito especial também que
nessa fase eu comecei aí em alguns
encontros de parkour porque são
encontros de parkour são basicamente
três milhões onde as pessoas da
comunidade elas diversidade de diversos
estados ela se reúne pra simplesmente
trocar experiência e se divertir e ter
esse tipo de troca e eu participei de
diversos deles e fui conhecendo cada vez
mais pessoas e fui criando uma certa
relação com essas pessoas elas começaram
a se tornar tão especiais para mim que
quando eu percebi eu tinha os meus 12 13
anos e meus melhores amigos eles eram 10
mas dez anos mais velho do que eu e eu
continuei treinando continuei cada vez
mais atentando nesse universo do parkour
até 2016 que foi quando o ramo da cidade
até então eu juntamente com o irmão a
gente treina junto minha cidade e alguns
amigos dele também praticavam e tudo
mais
só que quando ele mudou de cidade e os
amigos dele também foram parando por
diversas razões
eu percebi que se eu quisesse continuar
com o parkour eu teria que continuar
treinando sozinha e aquilo ali foi um
desafio pra mim porque eu tinha meus 13
anos estava naquele meio da puberdade e
eu comecei a perceber que as pessoas à
minha volta não enxergava aquilo que eu
fazia uma forma muito positiva
eu tinha que às vezes andam na escola na
rua e tem que escutar os comentários
maldosos a respeito das roupas que usava
ou simplesmente do próprio conceito que
as pessoas tinham processo mulher
praticar o esporte
às vezes eu estava tranquila ele
treinando de repente alguém falava
porque sei que está fazendo muito
masculino ser coisa de homem observa the
machine e flávio julgar o outro lado
aquilo ali me machucava de alguma forma
eu fazer com que me retrair se só que eu
comecei a perceber que o parkour também
era um pouco da cura disso porque da
mesma forma como eu tinha que escutar
aquilo ali e eu me fechava usava um
movimento pra conseguir transmitir algo
me expressar
então o meu relacionamento com o barco
vai ficando cada vez mais forte
eu fui percebendo que ele me ajuda
também a criar uma certa autonomia para
conseguir me entender
e também dá uma guinada no que tinha à
volta
eu comecei a usar o movimento quase como
uma forma de meditação onde conseguia
focar naquilo ali e esquecer
simplesmente esquecer do que eu tinha
que escutar mais tarde em 2007 eu recebi
uma proposta eu havia treinado tanto m
entendido tanto sozinha que tinha tido
uma evolução muito rápida e esse é a
proposta para competir
internacionalmente pela primeira vez eu
não sabia muito como era competições de
parkour
eu não tinha nenhum conhecimento assim
dia
de barco no brasil mas eu resolvi e eu
venci minha primeira competição de
parkour aquilo para mim foi um choque
porque eu imaginava que ia conseguir
porque eu quando cheguei lá eu não
pensei muito e eu quero ganhar mas o que
eu queria fazer aquilo que eu sabia que
estava tudo bem e eu ter vencido foi o
que me motivou muito e me dão aquela luz
de esperança assim de falar cara eu acho
que talvez eu possa ter um futuro nisso
mas agora dá muito certo
quando voltei no brasil eu vi que a
mentalidade das pessoas à minha volta
ela tinha mudado um pouco não só a minha
mentalidade de realmente queira
continuar aquilo ali mas as pessoas à
minha volta mas começaram a respeitar um
pouco mais aquilo que eu fazia
simplesmente porque eu não sei só mais
aquela menina zoada que ficar o plano na
praça mas eu ter representado o nosso
país no exterior
então começaram a ficar cara mas a
teoria legal em e do mesmo ano em
setembro eu recebi uma oportunidade que
foi a de tentar me qualificar por vídeo
uma competição mundial que aconteceria
na suécia e juntamente com um amigo meu
de uma cidade vizinha
a gente fez esse vídeo e eu passei
quando sai o edital eu quase acreditei
porque as 16 meninas selecionadas ao
redor do mundo e eu era a primeira na
história da américa do sul a entrar
nesse evento
eu fui até lá essa foto oficial do do
banner do evento e foi lá onde
conquistei uma melhor primeiro sétimo
lugar da vida porque o choque de
realidade que eu tive quando cheguei lá
foi algo muito absurdo eu pude ver a
estrutura que duas pessoas tinham não só
para o treinamento porque eu havia
aprendido todos os movimentos na rua da
areia na grama eles tinham academia
tablado de ginástica fosso mas as
pessoas da cidade elas pagavam para
assistir parkour e ficar com a cabeça
muito absurda é muito longe do que
acontece no brasil
eu comecei a perceber também que as
competições de partículas funcionava de
uma forma diferente de todas que já
havia participado das pessoas elas se
apoiavam o ambiente mais leve
o mundo ele quisesse que outra razão se
fosse muito bem ea gente quisesse dar um
show e eu me lembro que eu estava lá do
lado com pessoas que eu havia crescido
assistindo é uma inspiração para mim e
ela estava ali me apoiando simplesmente
processo por também falou que mexeu
muito com um estado mental e me fez
querer continuar me fez querer ir atrás
desse sonho até essa profissionalização
e foi quando cheguei no brasil que eu
conversei com os meus pais e eu comecei
a pensar que a cidade pequena tinha
estourado pequena demais que tamanho do
meu sonho eu queria para a cidade grande
eu queria ir atrás disso
e aquele tamanho de um mundo que eu
tinha eu percebi que ele podia se
transformar em algo maior mas eu teria
que mudar e eu me mudei eu vim pra
cidade grande
só que quando eu cheguei aqui foi o
choque porque eu percebi que eu não
sabia viver na cidade grande
eu não sabia como pegar busão eu não
sabia como fritar um ovo ela sabe fazer
o arroz
ela sabia cuidar de casa e tinha meus 15
anos eu tive que aprender em um ambiente
totalmente novo e percebi que aquela
realidade que vive lá é totalmente
limitada e foi quando eu comecei a
entender um pouco do quanto aquele tempo
que eu tinha passado sozinha treinando
me fez crescer e evoluir e criar uma
certa autonomia pra conseguir me
entender e superar esse tipo de coisa
então eu comecei a buscar formas de
conciliar estudo com o treino como a
vida pessoal
só que foi um desafio pra mim e muitas
vezes desanimava eu ficava pensando cara
mas será que eu devo mesmo tentar isso
eu não tenho nenhum caminho para seguir
eu preciso criar meu próprio trajeto
eu preciso tentar inventar algo novo e
inovador precisa arriscar
às vezes parecia mais fácil na minha
cabeça eu simplesmente voltar para a
cidade e ficar perto dos meus pais as
pessoas que eu amava porque é mais
confortável poderia ter seguido minha
vida lá e ter ficado no conforto estava
tudo bem seria bem mais fácil
mas quando você arrisca você tem
conhecimento do ambiente que você está
jogando e disse mesmo isso não se torna
algo perigoso porque você sabe que você
está fazendo
tem conhecimento se você chega ou não
e foi a partir dessas reflexões e
comecei a enxergar aquilo que estava
vivendo como se fossem salvos no parkour
onde você os observa
você sabe se você chegou não sabe que
existe a possibilidade dia mas aquela
envolve tantos gases
isso reduz totalmente a possibilidade de
você errar mas ela ainda existe só que
se você erra você não se machuca
você sabe como salvar uma queda
então comecei a pensar que essas quedas
elas fazem com que você tenha maior
possibilidade de crescimento porque você
pode voltar ao ponto inicial
simplesmente corrigir alguma técnica
básica e realizar o salto com êxito
você pode simplesmente voltar entender
qual acusa falta para você completar
aquilo ali talvez demore em dias meses
anos mas você pode voltar e realizar e
quando você faz isso
a felicidade que você tenha um absurdo
porque você entende que você que você
aproveitou aquele processo de errar você
usou aquele o seu favor você cresceu com
aquilo eu comecei a pensar no qual não
linear trajetória é o contexto antes de
altos e baixos
enquanto esses momentos baixos são
importantes para que a gente consiga
evoluir o quanto você aproveitar o
caminho aproveitar o processo faz com
que você cresça faz com que você não
seja a mesma pessoa de ontem
você não seja a mesma pessoa amanhã você
dá valor a esses movimentos sutis e
pequenas do cotidiano faz com que você
aprender cada vez mais e por mais que no
fim das contas esse objetivo ele não se
concretize porque muitas vezes nosso
objetivo não dependem só de nós depende
de empresas dependem de pessoas dependem
de outras companhias e permite diversos
fatores mas se você viveu intensamente
esse processo e não você não é mais a
mesma pessoa
então você pode usar essa mesma
dedicação que você usou para chegar
neste objetivo para qualquer outra área
da sua vida e eu com 17 anos que eu não
entendi isso eu comecei a entender que
eu poderia usar essa a indicação que o
dia dos treinos
os estudos no relacionamento com as
pessoas
qualquer coisa que eu quisesse fazer
aquele sentimento que eu tinha de
incapacidade quando era criança ele
morreu porque aquilo ali me fez ser mais
confiante daquilo que estava fazendo ele
fez com que eu criasse sua autoconfiança
e realmente me sentir se capaz então eu
tenho alguma deixar para vocês eu queria
dizer principalmente que a gente não
precisa esperar para ser feliz
só na linha de chegada